[Music]
in cards against the wall news cards
against the wall submitted by mr.
Brightside hey cards against humanity'
bought land in attempt to stop Trump's
border wall what whoa the game that's
wild
you could buy borderland they did this
project and next to the border also you
could obstruct it or like oh my god
or it's a business move and Trump's
gonna buy that land from them for four
times the price that they bought it for
that's all they really are cards against
humanity' I'm gonna play a video where
they tell you guys their plan with cards
we played that game check it out on just
getting party yeah a couple of things a
shameless plug
do they even like us do this I wish this
northern la I don't mean either they did
invite cards against humanity' launched
a bold campaign to save America
these scrappy comedy writers would come
to be hailed as saviors by the American
people
they stopped Trump's border wall solved
the problem of fake news and ended the
creeping scourge of homework the
struggle was real things just kept
getting worse
Wakaba video it happened
cards against humanity' announced this
crazy holiday marketing campaign and it
only cost
[Music]
that's a hilarious ad so I guess we got
the short version so the longer version
here they explain what happens and what
they're doing is they are trying to stop
the wall from happening right so it's
through this whole Christmas campaign
happening where you pay $15 15 and then
there's gonna be six surprise prizes
that you're gonna get in the mail for
whoever participates in this which is
already all sold out and so for the
first one they're gonna get a map of
where along the Mexico and US border
they bought this property and so what
they're trying to do is every single
person that paid $15 they get a portion
of this land and so when Trump is gonna
try to go and build the wall they need
to have like the super long crazy legal
process to be able to get every single
owner of this plot of land to agree to
the wall so that's why they're just
trying to elongate this process and make
it super expensive for Trump to even get
the wall built on this particular plot
of land so that's like the first thing
and then so throughout the month of
December they're gonna be coming out
with all these other surprises that
they're trying to save America with how
big is this a lot of land
you just like it as a matter like
lawyers on the back and they're like
this will delay the process for a full
presidential term
how old is Trump like 82 years old Dahl
948 late 60s or something oh really yeah
you made it late mid to late 60s I think
it all comes from the inside out cuz he
drinks water from a water bottle like
he's 90 years old
what is that look I mean because if
you're if you're a young person somebody
has your values you know as long as I'll
be able to eat water because they don't
know where the lips are did mr. Trump it
so I assumed that he was like 80
something years old just from the way he
drinks water you know how stupid I am I
thought we already had a wall that's why
I was like why do we need another one
yeah I thought
don't we like a plane offense no there's
a wall when you go to TJ there's a legit
oh yeah yeah I think it doesn't go all
the crosstalk yeah it's just at the
border area that does it just it doesn't
go all the way to Texas to Louisiana
yeah oh I see that's just the crossing
wall well I see it for miles and miles
and every time do you remember that show
it was like [ __ ] it was like cops but
it's like border guards or some [ __ ] and
then every time they were by the wall
they were just always around the wall I
was just assuming that that wall went
for miles and miles that's really cool
and it's cool that someone or like
people like game board creators are like
trying to make you know a wave like it's
big oh yeah that's really the plan so
next level I don't even know what to
make of it so I'm like it's so next
level where I'm like is this kind of
like not a hoax but what do they call
those like a mockumentary or like yeah
that commercial is [ __ ] hilarious
like it seems very sarcastic so I don't
know if it's like one of those funny
Dollar Shave Club acts type of ads or
Old Spice type of ads or is it really
this is what they're trying to do where
with $15 a bunch of people can own all
this land and then it's to really
prevent from from doing what he wants to
do I might sound stupid again but what
why is it bad to have a wall I mean
Hispanics just amazing although wait
though the wall issue was the fact that
there it's it's [ __ ] expensive as
[ __ ] it's it's costing twenty billion
dollars for no reason because it and
it's not gonna stop anybody not gonna do
anything like if people want to get by
they're gonna get by no matter what yeah
yeah I mean that's true just a big waste
of money and animals not only that
there's a bunch of creating divisive MS
between our neighbors yeah I would
represent oh that's true okay that makes
sense now because I was just okay so
like my mind went to like okay so if
people illegally crossed a border and
then like we can't regulate who does and
who doesn't then wouldn't it make sense
to build a wall it makes sense to me
right but then to make it a big wall
I'll call it the great wall of America
people could take pictures on it yeah
but if it's super expensive then yeah I
guess
and then he's demanding the Mexico
fronts the cost oh yeah that's right
that's right that's a buddy like what
[ __ ] you
there's too many Mexicans in the u.s. to
where you don't want it you want you
don't want to create more divisive nough
so many Mexican or like citizens in the
u.s. that you know I love Mexican people
specifically this place called Avenue 26
I am there a fish I kid you [ __ ] it not
idle legit and their official mascot
person Avenue 26 tacos is the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I love Cesar what's up I love that
[ __ ] you should make a cardboard
cutout of you and then you're just like
this and then your fans could take
pictures of he'll look like the he'll
look like the Korean barbecue makan go
dong yeah I would [ __ ] love it dude I
love that place so much it's like a
sombrero cuz I talk about Avenue 26 so
often like there's he tells me that fans
always go there that's high just so they
could see me this kills like do I can't
believe I found you I was like it's not
really that surprising I mean like six
times a week
like yeah you'll see me quite often here
actually I love that place so we always
go at night get like a few tacos we
dance to the music
trying to get a horchata or tapa oh I
like the H though you know Mexican
culture is pretty much like the same
thing as American Southwest culture like
you can't have Southwest culture without
Mexican well yeah they took most of it
from Mexican culture it wasn't that long
ago that it was Mexico here right so
like everything in the southwest like so
I going to the East Coast I go okay this
is like New England this is this is like
that old you know Cuban next you know
like it you feel you feel the European
assist right the bill T the Midwest
yeah same thing but then when you're
here and when you grow up in the
southwest you feel the Spanish nests
or the Mexican s you know like the
history the roads the names of the
cities everything so I it's like to me
that is America I just like tacos if I
don't have tacos it's a pretty bad week
yeah song cards against humanity's
website for this particular campaign
it's called cards against humanity'
saves America calm and then they have a
frequently asked questions page one of
these questions it says I don't like
that you're getting political why don't
you just stick to card games and their
answer is why don't you stick to seeing
how many Hot Wheels cars you can fit up
your [ __ ]
oh my god I'm gonna buy even more even
though we ready own card you can do
vanities I know they will game but yeah
I mean what are your thoughts on the
fact that they are getting political now
when you're just a card game other
people and get political whatever the
hell they want people I think they like
they put everything into little box
people act outside of it then they start
freaking out but it's like who cares if
Disney wants to get political if yes PN
wants to get to let people get political
like what is it fun yeah I don't care if
I agree or disagree I think it's pretty
dope that they have a position and they
stick with it and they don't play this
[ __ ] let's try to be you know
apologetic about everything I love the
response
I love the [ __ ] stick of Hot Wheel
car up your ass if you don't like it
like that's how I want more companies to
act like I mean it's cards against
humanity's - I mean they suck they want
I mean it's not like it's Toys R Us or
some [ __ ] Street I mean like come on
imagine if Hot Wheels did that how we
lose like we support Trump stick a
[ __ ] how they send him Hot Wheels
over to the White House yeah
there's no getting political though
right because like politics affects
everybody so you're just being more
involved in what's affecting you I think
anyone that owns a business will try to
use that business for whatever agenda
like that's it's a week but that's the
whole point though right all the media
companies outside of Fox is all
left-wing so they're gonna report you
know bias left-wing news I mean that's
news though I guess where we're talking
about here is like different like a
board game like the fact that they are
getting political cuz then but
it's the same as this news it's not like
we're all here trying to be like you
know just super like you said apologize
or like take everybody's side and be
like PC it's okay we hear the topic and
we feel a certain way we're gonna
express it and that's a platform we have
to do it you know what I mean / like if
there was only like one subscriber
nobody would give a [ __ ] yeah I think
it's different because what she's saying
is like like if monopoly came out and
said we love Trump yeah well it's kind
of it there's there's no real like
relation to any sort of like Avenue that
they that shows that they're like in in
the politics at all like they've never
once been like you know rallying for I
don't know like you didn't hear cards
against humanity' was like voting for
like Hillary or whatever to like win the
presidential election right so it's like
it kind of just came out of nowhere that
these people are being held a bold and
not only just being vocal about it but
actually like yeah putting their money
where their mouth is and like they're
like going above and beyond to really
make a statement so it's kind of really
cool and kind of odd that like like I
personally love it cuz like in this
climate everyone wants to be so [ __ ]
PC and like take care of all like the
[ __ ] sensitive people and like oh I
don't know if and just kill them let's
kill them all and these people are like
yeah like like they're just being
jaekeun about it where they're just like
hey we have a position we're gonna stand
with it if you don't like it [ __ ]
[ __ ] shove it up your ass yeah
there's another question on there
frequently asking it said its cards
against humanity' being politically
correct now and their answer is just
we're just being regular correct
I like that let's pull it how are they
being politically correct because now
that they're stopped being the the wall
cuz they're like oh you're against the
wall that means you're stupid
politically correct I will say this no I
think people's political views do not
change my opinion about the person at
all because I was watching some
interviews of with Dana White and he's a
I guess like you like a huge Trump
supporter I still watch UFC yeah exactly
if you're a scumbag it doesn't matter
what political views exactly yeah and
another hole politically correctness is
getting way too crazy where like is just
now people don't even want to be
considered liberals anymore because now
being a liberal it's like now you're
just negative super crazy
getting out of hand yeah and if girls
have an opinion and they're feminist and
said what yeah it's not a rocker and
either that or it's like if you say
something wrong
oh [ __ ] so I'm gonna get triggered it's
like wait you mean someone's gonna have
an opinion but I guess it's getting
triggered I don't know it's so weird
right now I [ __ ] hate it
shup hot wheels up your ass no you don't
have to hate anything you just got
living your own world
that's truly Maya yeah limo wrong you're
[ __ ] that's really insensitive I'm
like really yeah my mind is mine
[Music]